So gehts wieder, ey ich krieg anfälle.
Es reicht jetzt auch, morgen geht die Kündigung raus, ich hab echt keinen Bock mehr.
Ich werde das scheiß kündigen, es hat echt keinen Sinn.
Ich muss mal gucken wie es da aussieht mit Fristen und ich werde es so machen, dass ich
natürlich Übergangslos was hab, also sprich ich werde den Telekom Anschluss wieder abschließen.
Was haben die grad so?
Keine Job-Suche, Internet und DSL, was haben wir dann halt gerade so?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken was es bei mir gibt, das werd ich jetzt hier nicht onstream machen,
halt das ist ein bisschen blöd, also was gibt es bei mir, ich werde mal kurz schauen, 250
MBit Download und 40 MBit Upload, das ist doch, ist doch top, kann man bei der Telekom
irgendeinen Power-Upload oder sowas, ne, also da nehmen wir mal Internet und DSL, das da,
das gibt es bei mir, wo kann man checken ob es Glasfaser-Telekom gibt, gut wenn ich hier
sag mal, wenn ich hier Verfügbarkeits-Check mache und der spuckt bei mir maximal das aus,
dann gibt es bei mir auch kein Gigabit Glasfaser oder, ne also immerhin es geht, es wurde von
heute wieder RIP, aber sowas von, aber sowas von ist da RIP, das muss weg, Vodafone muss
weg, gibt keine Alternative, Vodafone muss weg, Vodafone get out, aber ohne das Herz,
nur den, ich mein dann hab ich halt anstatt 400 down, 40 up, hab ich dann halt 250 down
und 50 up oder 40 up oder was auch immer, ähm, scheiß drauf, dafür funktioniert, ist
doch der Witz, guck dir den Scheiß mal an, ey, und jeden Stream Leute, jeden Stream ist
das so mittlerweile, jeden Stream, ja das geht, jeden Stream, jeder, also jeder, es ist ja
nicht mal jeder zweite Stream, 90% der Streams ist das, mehrfach, mehrfach, wenn es am Anfang
mal 5 Minuten kurze ruckeln würde, was auch immer, warum wie auch immer das sein sollte,
dann ähm, hast du dann tatsächlich 400 down, ja doch, doch ziemlich, ziemlich gut, also
down, das klappt bei mir meistens, sind ja nur ein paar fehlende Frames, es fehlt ja,
es fehlen ja kaum was, ey, immerhin, ja, 2,3% der Bilder kommen ja noch an, und bei 60
Bilder in der Sekunde sollte das doch eigentlich ausreichen, ja, 0,3 Bitrate, 0, ja, da werd
ich mir sowas hier holen, 55 Euro nimmt sich auch nicht viel, ja, hä, ah hier, 50, ah,
Fiber, ja, ich hab ja kein Fiber, ich krieg ja nur VDSL, also, warum ist das Internet
in Deutschland so abgrundtief für Scheiße, ey, warum hat Uganda besseres Internet, okay,
keine Ahnung ob Uganda besseres Internet hat, aber wahrscheinlich, Uganda Internet Provider,
guck mal mal, Smile Communications, Breitbandchecker in Uganda, okay, zeig mal her, also, geh weg,
wir leben in Gulu, Gulu, na gut, die sind vielleicht doch nicht so gut in Uganda, also
in Gulu, Gulu ist nicht so gut, Gulu hat nur 8 MBit, wie siehts denn in Jinja aus, oh,
noch schlechter, ja, ja, ja, also, Uganda, Uganda, Uganda ist tatsächlich noch schlechter
als wir, Speedtest Global Index, ja, okay, wo sind wir denn, die Araber, sind wir hier,
sind vorne 85 MBit, Südkorea, ja, die sind gut, Katar, China, ja, aber es muss, Corona
liegt an 5G aus China, ganz klar, was muss da aufklappen, was muss ich aufklappen, ne,
wat, he, Show All, ach hier, ach, dass wir überhaupt drinstehen, du musst tatsächlich
aufklappen, dass wir drinstehen, das ist auch geil, keckw, huge, lass den Scheiß mal eingeblendet,
so, dann haben wir, was ist das eigentlich für ex, für ex, excellent, äh, 5-Hat-Musik,
so, also, Südkorea, Katar, China, Kanada, Niederlande, ähm, was ist das, ach so, das
ist mobile, mobile, verguckt, äh, mobile interessiert mich nicht, fixed, ist das interessante,
Singapur, Hongkong, Romania, äh, was ist das, ähm, Rumänien, Rumänien, gut, Rumänien
ist auch nicht so groß, äh, Thailand, Schweiz, Monaco, Frankreich, ich mein, die Franzosenkrisen,
ach, gebacken, Macau, weiß gar nicht, wo das ist, Schweden, Dänemark, die Amis, Andorra,
gut, das sind ja auch alles kleine Furzländer, da ist es auch nicht so schwierig, da stellst
da ein, ein, äh, Knotenpunkt zur Verfügung und gut ist, Spanien, Ungarn, Norwegen, Kanada,
Südkorea, aber die sind ganz schön runtergegangen, Luxemburg, Niederlande, China, Taiwan, Seeland,
Portugal, Licht, ist das Lichtenschein, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, Lettland oder sowas,
wir tauen, ok, eins, eins davon, eins davon, äh, die Araber, die Japaner, das ist jetzt
Lettland, ja, Polen, Katar, Germany, Wahnsinn, so, was, was ist denn so bei uns in der Nähe,
ok, also wir sind so quasi auf einem Level mit Schiele, Austria, Austria, wo sind sie
denn, oh, die sind ja noch schlechter, österreichisches Komponett-Ripfer, wer ist denn so unten da,
Turkmenistan, ah ja, alles klar, ich weiß gar nicht mal, wo Turkmenistan überhaupt
liegt, äh, ja, die, die Sachen, der Index hier ist nicht so gut, das ist die Leute,
die auf der Seite Speedtests machen, sind da drinnen, man müsste sich den generellen
Ausbau angucken, weil sprich, die, wenn man genommen, es gibt ein Land, das, äh, nur
ein Prozent Internet-Ausbau hat, dafür schnell, wäre hier wahrscheinlich relativ gut, ok,
Turkmenistan und Venezuela, Algerien, Jemen, da gab es nur noch eine andere Seite, Internet,
Seite, Index, Speed, ich hab da noch so eine andere Seite, wo war das denn, ok, es gibt
sogar ein Wikipedia-Eintrag für, oh man, warum ist das bei uns so scheiße, ok, ok,
ok, ok, echt,
...
Weißt du was ich mache?
Ich probiere das echt mal aus, ich streame das nächste Mal echt über den VPN, einfach
mal gucken, ob wir irgendwie was finden, wo die Routen nicht so scheiße sind.
Ist das F0, ja, huge, ne nicht mit NordVPN, ich nenne mal das Sebaro VPN.
Und ich werde das so machen, dass auch nur Twitch über das VPN geht, muss ich mal gucken
wie ich das am besten mache.
Am besten den IP Block für den Server in Amsterdam über das VPN routen, muss ich mal
gucken wie ich das am besten mache.
Egal, wir gucken uns jetzt das Video weiter an mit dem Historiker, der auf Assassin's
Creed reagiert.
Dass wir das noch schaffen.
Das Symbol eben auch hier wieder einer der Raben Odins, wieso hier keine anderen Götter
verehrt werden?
Einer reicht, ich kann eh nur bis drei zählen, da bleibt für Odin gleich noch zwei Slots
im Hirn frei.
So, da kommen wir jetzt zu anderen Gestaden und da kommen wir ja immer auch gleich dahin,
wo, nehme ich mal an, ein Großteil des Spiels auch spielen wird, nämlich im heutigen England.
Das finde ich allerdings sehr gut, was hier gemacht wird.
Hier wird so ein bisschen auch auf eine Problematik angespielt, die es in der Geschichte gibt,
gerade in der Geschichtsschreibung und die heutzutage in der Geschichtswissenschaft
ein bisschen aufgeklärt wird und zwar die meisten Quellen, die wir haben...
Ja, meinst du das hier?
Das hier ist QO-Notes, habe ich hier gerade am Start.
Kannst du jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich es jetzt auf dem anderen Code nicht habe.
Über, ein Anführungszeichen, Wikinger, sind von Menschen, die von Wikigern geschrieben
haben, weil die skandinavische Bevölkerung selten selbst Textquellen oder Bildquellen
angefertigt hat.
Deswegen sind die meisten Quellen, die wir heutzutage noch haben, natürlich etwas gefärbt
und schreiben eben von Wikigern oder Nordmännern als Barbaren, die alles abschlachten, was
ihnen in den Weg kommt und was hier so ein bisschen relativiert wird mit dem Spiel auch,
dass es eben nicht so ist, ist natürlich hier wieder so ein bisschen das Narrative, was
für das Spiel wichtig ist, da man, nehme ich mal an, einen Nordmann spielt, einen Skandinavier,
glaube ich jetzt mal, der auch Viking ist und dass man natürlich, der Protagonist kann
natürlich kein großer Abschlachtender mehr sein, gerade im Assassin's Creed-Universum
und was aber in dem Sinne hier sogar, sagen wir mal, historisch ist, insofern, dass zumindest
nicht alle Viking-Fahrten blutig geendet haben.
Was jetzt natürlich ein bisschen problematisch ist, weil hier sehen wir schon, die Umgebung
brennt, dass wir so ein bisschen, um es zu relativieren, bei dem Bildschirm, ich bin
jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Siedlungsforscher, aber das sieht mir schon ein bisschen dicht
besiedelt aus für die Zeit, in der das spielt.
Schöne Transition, die Frage ist, sind die Engländer die Bösen?
Nehme ich mal an, den Antagonisten, den großen, das habe ich mich auch gerade gefragt, ne,
ich nehme nicht vorweg, komm.
Und da, in diesem kleinen, in dieser kleinen Monolog, steckt eigentlich schon sehr viel
drin.
Also wir sehen hier, ich gehe erstmal darauf ein, wen wir überhaupt vor uns haben, und
zwar sehen wir hier an dem Siegel, was hier gerade aufgesetzt wird, Alfred Rex und hier
oben eben auch noch mal auf der Urkunde mit Unterschrift, na okay, wäre wahrscheinlich
wenn, dann eher ein Monogramm, nicht unbedingt so eine plane Unterschrift, hier haben wir
noch das Siegel mit demselben drauf, hier nochmal Alfred Rex.
Also hier haben wir es mit König Alfred, Alfred Rex, ne, ich wollte gerade einen blöden
Spruch mit Tyrannosaurus Rex machen, aber der war so cringe, den habe ich mir verknüffelt,
zu tun mit Alfred, dem später großen.
So, kurz zum Siegel hier, ein bisschen historisch, aber auch ein bisschen nicht tatsächlich,
das hier ist nicht das Siegel, was wir heutzutage Alfred dem großen zuordnen, also ich blende
das hier mal ein, wie das eigentliche Siegel Alfred des Großen aussieht, da sehen wir,
das ist ein bisschen abgetrennter, da hat zwar noch eine Umschrift, da steht aber, aber
dann, also das sieht doch relativ ähnlich aus, oder?
Siegulum Alfrici, achso Leute, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich die Bandbreite wieder hochstellen
kann, kann ich die Bandbreite wieder hochstellen?
Dann sieht es nämlich auch besser aus, ah yes, excellent, scheint wieder zu funktionieren.
Drauf und ist zwar auch ein Profil, aber ein anderes Profil, nämlich auf dem Siegel hat
er noch die Herrschaftszeichen und das ist eben Latein, hier haben wir in diesem Siegel,
was hier im Spiel benutzt wird, die angelsächsische Version und das hier ist eben, wieso sage
ich jetzt, ist historisch, wäre mir auch sofort aufgefallen, aber auch irgendwie nicht, es
ist in dem Sinne historisch, dass wir genau dieses Abbild Alfred des Großen haben, aber
es ist eben kein Siegel, sondern es ist eine Münzprägung von Ende des neunten Jahrhunderts,
ist es, ne?
Also Alfred, der Große, hat ja auch zweite Hälfte neunzig Jahrhundert, also von etwa
850 bis 900 gelebt und geherrscht und hier haben wir eben eine Bestätigung des Zeitrahmens,
den das Spiel hier abdeckt und eben auch der Charaktere, die darin vorkommen.
So, dann eben noch mal zu dem Monolog, der hier gehalten wird, spricht ihr darauf an,
sie werden diese Lande niemals verteidigen, sie werden es nie verstehen und sowas, da
spielt jetzt schon ein bisschen, also das ist nicht mehr während der großen Plünderungen
der Zeit, sondern da haben wir es schon mit der Dane-Law oder dem, wie kann man das richtig
übersetzen, dem Danengesetz oder dem Dänengesetz zu tun, das heißt, diejenigen, die jetzt
früher mal auf Wikingen als Plünderer oder eben auch teilweise als Siedler nach England
kamen und da eben kriegerisch oder nicht kriegerisch ihre eigenen Siedlungen erschaffen haben,
die sind schon im englischen Einzugsgebiet heutzutage, sind sie schon sesshaft geworden.
Das heißt, wir spielen die nicht mehr in der Ära Lindisfar, also die frühen Raubzüge,
sondern wir haben hier schon etwas mit der Dane-Law zu tun und es gibt auch schon excellent
Information, in Anführungszeichen, Wikinger-Siedlungen.
Der muss das jetzt ausmachen für die bessere Kameraüberblendung.
Da kommen wir jetzt gleich zu dem für mich sehr interessanten Bereich dieses Trailers,
denn jetzt kommt es zur großen Kampfszene und eine Sache, die mir nicht unbedingt...
Hoffentlich sagt er was über die Feuerpfeile, das ist so fail, Alter.
...wie ein Actor oder jedem, dass du dich so ein bisschen halbwegs mit Militärgeschichte
beschäftigst, auffällt, ist, dass du hier trinkst.
Wie wär's eigentlich mit einem Helm?
Wie wär's mit einem Helm?
Ich wollte es gerade sagen, ich wollte es gerade sagen, er sagt es jetzt auch.
Niemand ein Helm.
Ja, wie wär's mit einem Helm?
Wenn wir uns das hier so angucken, das Boot ist voll mit Leuten.
Helm ist das Wichtigste, was du überhaupt anziehen musst.
Hier sehen wir es auch noch mal und niemand trägt einen Helm und das ist etwas, was auch
von Hollywood so ein bisschen propagiert wird, gerade auch wenn es um Thematik Vikings, so
die Serie geht, haben wir das ja auch im großen Fall.
Helm ist uncool.
Überlebenssackt.
Und eben auch in der Spieleindustrie, natürlich ist es bei Hollywood immer noch mal ein bisschen
anders, weil da will man natürlich, dass der Protagonist oder die Protagonisten immer
erkannt werden.
Das heißt, man kann ihnen natürlich keinen Helm aufsetzen, weil man hat viel Geld dafür
bezahlt, dass der Schauspieler jetzt mitspielt.
Und wenn wir dann sein Gesicht nicht zeigen, dann haben wir natürlich große Einbußen.
Und auch vom Verständnis her für die Zuschauer, die wollen natürlich immer sofort sehen,
wer hier wer ist auf dem Schlachtfeld, was natürlich sehr chaotisch sein kann.
Pass mal auf, als nächstes kommt raus G-Bait, das war der neue Battlefield-Trailer.
Und hier haben wir es in dem Fall auch, keiner der Wikinger hier trägt einen Helm.
Und wenn wir jetzt gleich auf die andere Seite gehen zu den Angelsacksen, da trägt wirklich
jeder einen Helm und daran können wir es eben sehr schnell sehen, okay, wir wollen hier
visuell einen Unterschied schaffen zwischen Wikigern und Angelsacksen, weil die einen
tragen Helm, die anderen nicht.
Und da kommt jetzt noch etwas dazwischen, nämlich Feuerpfeiler, Feuerpfeiler, es sieht
so glorreich aus, ist aber in Realität sehr, nicht wirklich realistisch.
Na gut, wenigstens sagt er das, das ist ja das, da bin ich ja froh, dass es der Historiker
wenigstens jetzt auch so sieht, dass Feuerpfeile Schwachsinn sind.
Da gibt es ja, da gibt es sehr viele Videos auf YouTube, die zeigen und die sagen, Leute,
das funktioniert auch überhaupt nicht, lass das mit den Feuerpfeilen, ich meine, es sieht,
es sieht cool aus, ja, wenn da so ein, wenn der Nachthimmel erleuchtet wird und am besten
noch so ein bisschen Nebel und dann kommen die Feuerpfeile da rein und dann fängt jetzt
gleich alles an zu brennen und das ist natürlich auch, man sieht mehr, weil es ist Nacht und
so was, ja, aber Feuerpfeile, nein.
Und vor allem, das ist so eine Sache, wo ich mir denke, das ist so fail, man, gerade Assassin's
Creed ist ja eine Reihe, die dafür bekannt ist, die Sachen, zumindest was Games angeht,
historisch immer ganz gut zu machen, es würde nie einer so sinnlos in die Schlacht chargern,
keiner, wollen die alle verrecken oder was, haben die alle keinen Bock und was macht der
da mit seiner Axt eigentlich, will er den jetzt mit der Axt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
mit dem stumpfen Ende irgendwie eins in den Bauch schlagen oder?
Die Schlachtszene interessiert uns natürlich vom militärhistorischen Standpunkt etwas
mehr, hier wird einfach komplett alles aus dem Fenster geworfen, was ist ein Schildwall,
ich habe nie davon gehört, wir haben einfach zwei Seiten, die...
Es würden beide im Leben nicht so machen, erstens, es würde keiner mit Schwert und Schild
anrücken, die würden alle beide, zumindest die Engländer, hätten sie Schild und ein
Speer am Start und sie würden nicht sinnlos ineinander rein chargern, die würden in Formationen,
die sind alle lebensmüde, Alter.
Auf einander losrennen und hier sieht man eben auch noch mal hier unten, das sind alles
die Wikken.
Null Formation.
Und das sind alles die Angelsachsen, woran erkennt man das, die einen haben keine Helme
an, die anderen haben Helme ab.
Und die einen sind blau und die anderen sind rot.
Gut, dass die sich so eingefärbt haben, dass man das gleich erkennt.
Ich muss sagen, die Seite mit mehr Helmen gewinnt meistens auch.
Okay, allerdings fliegen da schon die Köpfe und man hat...
Der Helm hat nichts gebracht.
...in guter alter Action-Manier die Rüstungen, die hier gezeigt werden, bringen natürlich
kaum etwas.
So, da haben wir auch noch mal den Antagonisten, bzw. diesmal ist es nicht Alfred.
Ja, ne, das stimmt, ist tatsächlich so.
In ganz vielen Schlachten, auch in Filmen und Spielen, bringen Rüstungen nichts.
Wo man sich dann halt fragt, warum haben die alle Rüstungen an, wenn die nichts bringen.
So nach dem Motto, hop, zack, Rüstung durch.
Außer beim Endgegner.
Beim Endgegner bringt die Rüstung dann auf einmal was.
Man kann jetzt spektakulieren, wer genau es ist.
Da gibt es einige Spekulationen.
Es wurde noch nicht absolut bestätigt, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe.
Aber es gab ja einige Fürsten, die für Alfred und unter Alfred gegen die Dänen und die
Norweger und die Schweden, generell wie gesagt, in Anführungszeichen, die wir gekämpft haben.
Ja, Kingdom Come ist auch eines der wenigen Spiele, die mittelalterliche Verhältnisse
ganz gut darstellen.
So, da sehen wir es auch nochmal ganz schön.
Jetzt wird erstmal gelootet, der Typ muss erstmal gelootet werden, zumindest den Helm
kann man sich looten.
Überall die Leute, die keine Helme anhaben und die Leute, die Helme anhaben.
Im Übrigen auch noch eine Sache zu den Schilden an sich.
Ich habe ja eben schon mal die Raben Odins, gerade dieses Symbol der Raben Odins hier
genannt.
Zu den Schilden an sich, gerade die von den Nordmännern, relativ gut gemacht, muss man
tatsächlich so sagen, ja hier Planken so ein bisschen gebogen tatsächlich auch noch mit
relativ authentischen Schildbuckel drauf, umrandet, so wie es aussieht, nicht mit Metall,
so wie das in vielen Klischees behaftet gemacht wird.
Also kein Metallrand, sondern wahrscheinlich eher Rohhaut, Leder, in seltenen Fällen Leinen,
aber gut, okay.
Was mir da noch ein bisschen fehlt, ist die Leinenbespannung.
Also wir haben einige Funde mit Leinenbespannung, wir haben einige wenige Funde, die so roh
sind, also wo man auch die Holzplanken, wenn man es will, so sieht.
Wobei man sagen muss, ja okay, die Leinenbespannung ist in dem Setting wohl realistischer.
Ja also die Leinenbespannung der Schilde da, das war auch eines der ersten
Sachen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, so geht es nicht, aber er hat ja vollkommen recht, ich
mein er hat die ganze Sache ja noch viel detailreicher erzählt, aber so ein paar Sachen sind mir
ja auch schon aufgefallen, die nur ja fragwürdig sind, die gibt es halt im DLC, die Leinenbespannung.
Ohne irgendeine Bespannung drauf geht einfach nur mit Malung, kann vorgekommen sein, wie
gesagt, wir haben da einige wenige Funde, wobei man auch nicht weiß, ob die jetzt nur
zeremoniellen Aspekt haben oder ob die wirklich kriegerischen Aspekt haben.
Was ich immer geil finde, dass die immer Zeit haben in den Schlachten sich böse anzuschauen.
Das Setting finde ich cool, ich würde mir halt hoffen, dass die Darstellung in-game
halt ein bisschen näher an der Realität ist.
Zum großen Endkampf, den ich auch sehr interessant finde, war zum einen erstmal hier schön
schwer ins Bein gestochen, ich bezweifle, dass der gute Mann jetzt noch stehen kann,
aber meine Güte ja, ich will da jetzt nicht reinversitzen, da kann man stehen, kann natürlich
auch eine Rolle spielen und es gibt Belege durch die Geschichte hinweg, wo Menschen mit
schweren Verletzungen noch weitergekämpft haben, ohne wirklich sich was anmerken zu
lassen.
Aber ich meine, so ruhig, wie er ist, okay, der hängt auch überhaupt nicht, das hier
ist die Szene des ganzen Trailers, dass die Rüstung was bringt, wie er aufsteht hier
und ihm voll eine mitgibt gegen die Rüstung und es passiert einfach nichts.
Aber je nachdem, was der drunter hat, wenn du so eine Achse in die Rippen kriegst, habe
ich auch so meine Zweifel, dass du einfach so, so als wäre nichts gewesen, ich meine,
du wirst nicht sterben dran, aber mal Luft holen musst du bestimmt.
So, das wie ich finde, top, beste Szene des ganzen Trailers, weil hier hat er tatsächlich
mal eine Rüstung, die auch ihren Job macht.
Wir haben hier gut Schuppenpanzer, ist jetzt natürlich die Frage, woher haben wir das
so oft, perfekt eingefangen, meine Güte, gucken wir mal da, natürlich Schuppenpanzer
ist so eine Sache, ja okay, wie realistisch ist das in dem Kontext, wir haben hier offensichtlich
eine sehr, sehr hochgestellte Person, vielleicht einen anderen Art...
Ohne Hals auf jeden Fall, ohne Hals und Gesicht haben wir da schon mal jemand.
Gerade mit dem Helm, gut der Helmbusch hier ist ein bisschen zu viel, ein sehr ornaten
Helm, den sehen wir gleich nochmal im Close-Up und hier eben eine ganze Schuppenrüstung.
Wie gesagt, in dem Setting hier, neuntes Jahrhundert oder spätestens neunzehntes Jahrhundert, englisches
Einzugsgebiet, ist so die Frage, ob es da nicht realistischer gewesen wäre, ein einfaches
oder vielleicht noch etwas verziertes Kettenhemd, stinkt noch mal als Kettenhemd, wenn ich hier
Kettenhemd sage, dann meine ich natürlich ein Anführungszeichen Kettenhemd, weil der
Terminus ist alles andere als korrekt, aber...
Ich finde es cool, da wenigstens einer den Plan hat, im Vergleich zu mir, ich habe ja
auch nur minimalst Ahnung aus YouTube Videos, er scheint den Gramm ja studiert zu haben.
Ja gut, lassen wir uns mal so stehen, wir wollen mal wahrscheinlich einfach herausstellen,
dass diese Person jemand sehr wichtig ist, jemand sehr stark ist, ist so eine Art Endgegner
halt eben.
Trotzdem, wie gesagt, beste Szene, das wird aber leider wieder so ein bisschen relativ...
Warum macht er ihn eigentlich nicht einfach platt?
Warum macht er ihn nicht einfach platt und boxt ihn jetzt erstmal ne Runde?
Das wird im Close-Up durch diese Szene, beziehungsweise kriegen wir es noch mal genau hin, hier so,
das Schwert, sagen wir mal kurz was zum Schwert, das ist sogar nicht historisch, sorry, dass
ich das jetzt so sagen muss, auch wenn ich gerade bei Hollywood...
Das kannst du rumdrehen und kannst dann irgendwie als Hammer verwenden und spielen und allem
Möglichen immer mal gerne ein Auge zudrücke, aber bei dem Schwert hier haben wir tatsächlich
etwas, was für die Zeit, für den geografischen und kulturellen Raum absolut nicht belegt
ist.
Nach Orkshot-Tabelle wäre das hier wahrscheinlich ein Typ 20a, also ein Schwert-Typus, der im
Grunde genommen erst im 14.
und 15.
Jahrhundert aufkommt.
Mit ein bisschen Fantasie könnte man sagen, okay, wenn man die Hohlkehle jetzt noch ein
bisschen zusammenrückt und so was, dann könnte es auch ein Typ 12a sein, aber selbst da sind
wir...
Ah, der Typ 12a, ganz klar.
...vom Schwert-Typus und von der zeitlich-geografischen Einsortierung im Bereich des 11., 12.
Jahrhunderts.
Wenn wir ganz früh gehen, so das früheste 12a, was wir belegt haben, ist um das Jahr
15.000, also haben wir hier ungefähr, also mindestens mal, mit viel Fantasie haben wir
mindestens mal eine zeitliche Diskrepanz von 200 Jahren.
Mit wahrscheinlich etwas realistischer Diskrepanz haben wir hier eine zeitliche Differenz von,
sagen wir mal, 600 Jahren.
Also das Schwert in dem Kontext fragwürdig.
Noch eine Sache, sehen wir uns jetzt gleich nochmal, oder habe ich schon ein bisschen
übersprungen?
Auch hier nochmal sehr schön zu sehen, der Seerornate-Helm, das muss schon sehr, sehr
hochgestellterartiger sein.
Nee, ich hab's ein bisschen übersprungen.
Dann gehen wir nochmal ein bisschen zurück, weil ich wollte nochmal auf die Schilder
der Gegner eingehen, der Angelsachsen hier, finde ich irgendwo zufällig ein gutes Bild
hiervon, wenn wir hier so ein bisschen querbeet durchgehen.
Übrigens, die Äxte, die hier teilweise gezeigt werden, das ist schon so, befinden wir uns
auch sehr im Bereich der Fantasie, oder zumindest des Unpraktikablen.
Nee, ich finde gerade irgendwie nicht so den passenden Screen, wo es wirklich gut zu zeigen
wäre.
Aber worauf ich hinaus möchte, sehen Sie, glaube ich, im Hintergrund von hier noch irgendwo.
Jetzt bin ich gar nicht, jetzt habe ich es ja voll vergessen.
Wir haben es auf jeden Fall bei, wo die Leute hier zusammen, wo die hier hinstürmen.
Genau.
Hier sehen wir es so ein bisschen.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr euch das Video nochmal komplett anguckt, da ihr findet auch bessere
Szenen jetzt hier.
Aber hier sehen wir es, die ganzen Angelsachsen sind ausgerüstet mit Tropfenschilden, Kiteschilden,
sogenannten Normannenschilden, wie ihr es auch nennen möchtet, auf jeden Fall diese
Art tropfenförmige Schilde.
Hier sehen wir es nochmal besser, also die, die oben so abgerundet sind, die laufen dann
hier unten ein bisschen spitzer zusammen, haben unten auch so eine kleine Rundung, eben
auch mit so einem Schildbuckel hier drauf.
Und hier haben wir auch so, ja, okay, vielleicht wollte man wieder eine visuelle Differenz
herstellen zwischen den Wikingern und den Angelsachsen hier.
Ja, man braucht vor allem genug Sachen, die man looten kann, das schaue ich dich.
Ja, vielleicht, eventuell, ja, mit ein bisschen Fantasie eventuell, Tropfenschilde, nenne
ich sie jetzt mal, wie gesagt, gibt da verschiedene Termini für, ich nenne es jetzt sehr einfach
halt erst mal, Tropfenschilde, sind weit verbreitet so im Bereich 11.
12.
Jahrhundert.
Also da haben wir auch wieder etwa eine Diskrepanz von 200, 300 Jahren.
Ach ja, komm, draufgeschissen, 300 Jahre.
Die frühesten Tropfenschilde, die belegbar sind, kommen auf Ende des zehnten Jahrhunderts
und das sind wirklich die wirklich alle frühsten Beispiele.
Da haben wir noch nicht mal es zu tun mit archäologischen Funden, sondern wir haben
es hier, wir haben es da nur zu tun mit einer Bildquelle aus, ich glaube, das war, irgendwann
aus dem Otto dem Dritten, Manuskript von Otto dem, oder für Otto den Dritten.
Jetzt ist er ganz, war ganz pingelig, ja.
Das heißt, hier auch noch mal mindestens eine...
Vielleicht ist er Fan von Schillen.
Von 100 Jahren.
Also auch wieder ein bisschen künstlerische Freiheit dazu.
Es ist doch gut, dass er das so genau macht.
So, und der Kampf ändert natürlich damit, dass hier noch eine versteckte Klinge, die
kann natürlich...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wann war das erste Assassin's Creed?
Nein, wann das gespielt hat?
Vor Christus irgendwann?
Nee, wann war das, wann hat das gespielt?
Nach Christus?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wann hat das gespielt?
Kreuzzüge, ja, gut, da gab es ein paar Kreuzzüge.
Stimmt, muss, muss, muss, eh, ganz egal, weil, weil, was mir gerade eingefallen ist, ähm...
Altair oder so hieß der Typ doch.
Da gucken wir nämlich einfach mal Geburtsdatum und sowas.
Äh, hier, so, das ist nach Assassin's Creed, ein Spiel quasi zeitlich, nach, ähm, nach
Assassin's Creed Valhalla und er musste sich da noch den Finger abschneiden.
Er musste sich noch den Finger abschneiden für krasses Stealthsplate und war nicht big
brain genug, einfach das oben zu montieren.
Und der Wikinger ist gleich mal auf die clevere Idee gekommen, warum sollte ich mir den Finger
abschneiden, ich mach einfach das versteckte, das hiddenplate einfach oben drauf.
Warum hat sich Altair nochmal den Finger abgeschnitten?
Spiel nicht fehlen und der Endboss geht zu Boden und der Antagonist guckt etwas aus
der Wäsche.
Und dann haben wir ganz viele Hashtags, think, äh, was haben wir da, live, äh, live, think,
fight, conquer, like a viking, ähm, gut, aber zum like a viking da hab ich ja am Anfang
schon mal was zu mir gesagt.
So, das wäre der Trailer gewesen, wo sind wir jetzt, oah, 26 Minuten ungefähr, ein
schönes Video, sehr nice, was kann ich zu dem Trailer sagen, ich finde den Trailer sehr
gut für das, was er ist, der Trailer macht Lust aufs Spiel, er zeigt das Setting, er
zeigt Protagonisten, Antagonisten so ein bisschen, wobei, wir haben es hier wahrscheinlich mit
einem vorgesetzten Antagonisten so eine Art Puppe zu tun, hier mit Alfred dem Großen
und dann im Hintergrund, welcher der bis jetzt noch unbestätigten anderen Charaktere der
Zeit das ist, wissen wir jetzt noch nicht so genau, kann König Elle sein, wer weiß,
gerade im Bezug auf die Serie Vikings, natürlich auch so ein bisschen optisch dran angelehnt,
kann auch im Bezug auf Antagonismus sein, das ist bestimmt in den Templerstelze, wobei,
wobei man sagen muss, dass dies in den letzten Assassin's Creed Teilen mit Templern und so
auch nicht mehr so, war eigentlich doch zweitrangig, oder?
Protagonisten sind ganz klar aufgestellt, ähm, alles in allem auch historisch gesehen
sehr gut gemacht, bis auf die Tatsache, dass man eben beim Rüstungsdesign, beim Waffendesign
und eben auch beim Schilddesign, hier haben wir eben noch mal ein bisschen besser dargestellt,
natürlich jetzt, wo ich nicht mehr drauf eingehen möchte, da haben wir natürlich die
Schilde auch noch mal extra gut gezeigt, ja, da wurde sich hier und da schon sehr viel
Freiraum genommen, das ist aber auch von einem Assassin's Creed Spiel zu erwarten.
So, soll das Assassin's Creed Spiel jetzt unbedingt so extrem?
Was ich ja cool finde, dass sie das so gemacht haben, die alten Wikinger, die sind blau und
die Engländer sind rot, die kann man wenigstens wunderbar unterscheiden, schöne Multiplayer-Farbe
übrigens auch.
Soll das sogar nicht sein, weil dann würde das Spiel sehr eintönig aussehen und gerade
wenn man sich zu den letzten Spiele anguckt, Odyssey und Origins, da will man natürlich
so ein bisschen auf Rollenspielsysteme und bessere Rüstung, bessere Waffen und so was
eingehend und wenn man dann alle Schilder, Speere, Schwerter im Zweifelsfall gleich aussehen
lässt, das wäre natürlich auch ein bisschen langweilig.
Das sind so die positiven Sachen, was mich an dem Trailer generell ein bisschen stört,
ist, dass natürlich mal wieder komplett auf Taktiken der Zeit, auf Auslösungen der Zeit
sind.
Das hat mich auch ein bisschen gestört.
Es wird alles ein bisschen aus dem Fenster geworfen für Action.
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Und...
Ich fände das cool, wenn man das mal ein bisschen realistischer darstellt.
Was mir allerdings auch noch sehr gut gefällt, ist, dass im Vergleich zu anderen Produktionen
jetzt, was Spiele angeht oder Hollywood etc., dass sehr wenig Schwerter vorkommen bis jetzt
auf die Protagonisten, sondern tatsächlich auch mehr Äxte, mehr Schilde, mehr Speere.
Speere vor allem, ja.
Wobei man dann sieht, die Frage stellen muss, wie das dann im fertigen Spiel aussieht,
weil gerade was Schilde angeht, da hat Assassin's Creed besonders nach Odyssey ja einen Ruf,
das ist etwas zu ignorieren, wo wir schon den Bereich hatten, okay, griechische Phalanx
ist eigentlich, da spielt der Schild die zentrale Rolle, genauso wie im angelsächsischen oder
auch nordischen Schildwall, da spielt der Schild die zentrale Rolle, heißt auch Schildwall
und nicht Schwertwall oder Sperrwall, von daher schauen wir mal, wie Assassin's Creed das
diesmal macht.
So, ich würde mich auf eure Meinung zu dem Trailer sehr freuen.
Ich freu mich sehr auf das Spiel, ich find's immer toll, wie die in Filmen und Trailern
und Spielen, wie lebensmüde die alle sind, so nach dem Motto, aha, Schlacht, auf geht's,
tot, Big Brain, keine Wunder, dass die's alle nicht so lang gemacht haben, Jolo, das ist
das mittelalterliche NA-Aim, was man da sieht, das ist wirklich NA-Aim aufs Mittelalter übertragen,
aber zeigen, wie dann irgendwelche Pfeile easy Rüstung durchschlagen und sowas, gerade
Pfeile über eine gewisse Distanz ist da mal gar nicht, und was man auch sagen muss, Grills
at the Beach, Boy, what the fuck, dass gerade die Bögen, die zur damaligen Zeit eingesetzt
wurden auf dem Schlachtfeld, die müssen wohl extrem schwergängig gewesen sein oder halt,
wie heißt das auf deutschland, sind sehr große Kraft dahinter, die du gespannt, die du spannen
musstest.
Also, so wie das in irgendwelchen Fantasy-Settings immer ist, so die zierlichen Elfen-Mädels
mit Bogen am Start und die harten Kerle mit ihrem Schwert, es wäre wahrscheinlich eher
umgedreht gewesen, weil die zierlichen Elfen-Mädels den Bogen überhaupt nicht gespannt bekommen
hätten.
Fix your internet for free, stand das irgendwo?
Barbecue Pit Boys, was haben wir sonst noch schönes hier?
Wir können uns ein Video, oh fuck, was hab ich jetzt hier zugemacht?
Ach so, Endzone, aber ich will jetzt eh nicht gucken.
Double New Clutch, wir könnten mal wieder ein MW2-Video gucken, einfach weil es geht.
Komm, wir gucken nochmal ein MW2-Video, einfach weil es geht.
Das Video unten links, how to double your internet speed for free, ja, okay, okay, mal
gucken, was wir da wieder debatet werden, oh, Microsoft Sam, Alter, was geht, lange nichts
mehr von dir gehört.
Komm mal, ich hab auch Microsoft Sam, aber sie hätten ja wenigstens, sie hätten ja
wenigstens mal Microsoft Header verwenden können, oder, Microsoft Header, Header ist
besser als Sam, oh man, Microsoft Sam, okay, Wodafone, ach nee, ich hab Wodafone gelesen
gerade, also Wiener Phone, okay, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's,
oh ja, zeig her, hä, hä, hat er überhaupt nichts gemacht, hat er überhaupt was gemacht,
hat er überhaupt nichts gemacht, hä, what, oh, jetzt kommt hier, hack, hacksaw, oh,
der hat den Steam Download auf dem anderen Rechner ausgemacht, ja, hä, was genau möchte
und sagen set bridge mode for hua yi routers
hua yi hua yi routers
uncheck lan2, lan3 und lan4
ich benutze vigor drahec router, um die speed der internet zu erhöhen
der drahec router hat zwei wan port
du kannst einen anderen router benutzen, z.B. tp-link, d-link
wire router hat zwei wan port
verbinden hua yi lan4 mit drahec wan1 port
verbinden hua yi lan3 mit drahec wan2 port
du kannst einen anderen router benutzen
Da muss ich erstmal so ein Gerät kaufen.
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was er macht.
Hä? Was, was macht er?
Okay, das da ist sein DSL-Modem, oder?
Das da ist sein DS-
Das da ist sein DSL-Modem.
Ist, ist das das sein DSL-Modem?
Wow, wow!
Wow, es geht jetzt ja!
Also erstmal haben wir den Arkenas,
noch 4 Monate haben wir es schon.
Danke schön, da kommt der Tanzer mit 10 Stufe 1 Abos.
Massive! Huge!
Subscribers hierin.
Gar nicht mal auf.
Dankeschön.
10 Abos. Poggers, Alter.
Massive. Wer kriegt denn die Abos?
Wer kriegt denn die Abos? Zeig mal her.
Beta, Dota, Meta, Dabenzel,
Dravorek,
Axel4199,
Defugo,
Micharro,
Sond,
Mario, der Trader,
David Schar und Muffin,
Cody,
Poggers, der Hype-
Level 4 Hype-Train, Leute!
Der Instant Level 4 Hype-Train
ist am Start.
Wahnsinn. Heute geht's ja hier
richtig. Schlag auf Schlag.
Die Meldungen, die Notifications
kommen überhaupt nicht hinterher.
Easy Money, easy life, so sieht's aus.
Ja, Dankeschön für die ganzen Abos.
Okay, ich versuche jetzt gerade noch mal
zu checken, was hier passiert gerade
in dem Video. Der hat seinen
DSL-Mode, das ist wahrscheinlich sein DSL-Mode.
Das Bridge, der irgendwie auf zwei Ports
war, was auch immer, genau.
Thomascool110,
vier Monate, Dankeschön.
Also der Chat-IQ ist ja gerade durch die ganzen
Zaps, das ist ja schon, also
eigentlich, eigentlich schon eher
eigentlich schon eher so gerade.
Das passt gar nicht mehr in die Köppe rein,
so groß ist der Chat-IQ heute.
Also nun mal so, dass ich
halbwegs checke. Das da ist
quasi sein, sein, nennen wir es mal
sein, sein Kabelmodem, DSL-
Modem, was auch immer.
Das hat er jetzt irgendwie angeschlossen
an einen normalen Router,
an einen Dual-Warn-
Security-Firewall,
oder ist das sein Modem?
Die Erklärung ist irgendwie sehr, sehr schäumig
und warum soll es das vor allem schneller machen?
Weil nur weil es zwei Kabel sind?
What?
Ok, schauen wir mal, was, was kommt jetzt?
Hä? Das hat doch wieder nichts geändert.
Ok, schauen wir mal, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt's drauf an.
Ach, hat er zwei Internet,
hat er, hat er zwei,
zwei, äh,
Internetanschlüsse und will die jetzt irgendwie
zusammen, oder was macht der da? Ich, es leuchtet
immer noch nicht ein.
Es ergibt
wenig Sinn, aber, äh, zeigen wir mal.
Ich mein, er wählt sich direkt ein über das,
das heißt, er verwendet das Ding wirklich als Modem.
Wählt er, wählt er sich doppelt ein,
oder was macht er da?
Wählt er sich doppelt ein,
aber dann muss er doch doppelt bezahlen,
wenn er zwei Accounts hat, oder so.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass es gar nicht so einfach ist,
mit, äh, zwei Internetleitungen
bridgeen, und man bekommt doppelten
Speed. Du kannst es auf der einen
Seite loadbalancen, ja, das funktioniert,
dann aber auch nur für mehrere Benutzer, beziehungsweise
mehrere Verbindungen. Für einen,
also für einen Download an sich, äh, funktioniert
das nicht.
Ansonsten bräuchtest du noch was im Internet
als, als Gegenstell, äh, mal gucken.
Es, es ist auf jeden Fall echt
fuß.
Also, ich mein, allein schon dadurch, dass es
balancet ist, dürfte der Speedtest,
wenn, wenn der Speedtest nur eine, ich weiß nicht,
wieviel Verbindungen der Speedtest so aufmacht,
äh, das nicht funktionieren.
Default root settings.
Select the newly created
profile 2.1.
Was?
Das ist wirklich komplett random Video,
oder?
Also, ich kann mir so ungefähr,
ich kann mir so ungefähr einen Reim
drauf machen, was er, was er, was er
gebastelt hat.
Ähm, guck mal, er kriegt,
er kriegt auch, er kriegt auch zwei unterschiedliche
IPs. Das heißt, er hat einen DSL
Modem, oder was auch immer,
ähm,
und
der wählt sich quasi
zweimal über das DSL Modem
ein, bei seinem Provider.
Was auch erstmal der Provider unterstützen
muss, geschweige denken,
ähm, dass das, dass das
bei den meisten Provider funktioniert,
bezweifle ich mal.
Und dann Load Balancer die Verbindung, das
funktioniert aber auch nur für mehrere
Verbindungen dann.
Also, was, was über, was,
das ist kompletter Blödsinn, wozu?
Vor allem braucht es da ein bisschen bessere Erklärung
dafür.
Also, ich würde sagen,
Leute, easy, wir sollten
das gleich mal mit meinem Vodafone-Anschluss
ausprobieren.
Okay, das war absolut
Fail-Video, äh.
Ne, echt nicht.
Echt nicht.
Muss nicht sein.
Huge success.
Mindestabstand.
Da hab ich jetzt echt keinen Bock drauf auf
dieses Thema.
Clean-Up-Windows-
Oh mein, es wird ja immer noch, es wird ja immer schlimmer
heute, was wir an Videos empfohlen kriegen.
Ach ne, das ist, das ist wie man, ähm,
wie man vorinstallierte Sachen
entfernt. Okay, das, das geht ja noch,
das geht ja noch in Ordnung.
Oh man, was Zeug.
Leute, ich muss mal dringend aufs Klo,
Leute, ich muss mal dringend aufs Klo.
Ich muss mal dringend aufs Klo
und ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ähm.
Ich glaub, wir machen gleich Schluss.
Oder?
Na, hm, mal gucken. Wann haben wir dann angefangen
zu streamen? Kann ich, kann ich dann überhaupt schon Schluss
machen? Sind wir denn, sind wir denn schon wach überhaupt?
Ich hab angefangen zu streamen,
um, nachdem das 20.000 Mal abgebrochen
ist, ich hab angefangen zu
streamen, um, ja, steht nicht
so genau da, vor drei Stunden,
das passt um 10. Doch, wir haben ziemlich pünktlich
um 10 angefangen, diesmal.
Wir haben ziemlich pünktlich um 10 angefangen, kann ich mich
auch dran erinnern. War wenigstens eine Sache,
die ich bemerken konnte. Ziemlich genau um
10.
Haben wir angefangen. Aber ich würde gerne noch mal
eine Runde MW2 gucken. Komm, Leute,
eine Runde. Eine Runde MW2 gucken wir
noch.
Hast du dir schon mal das Tuning
Pack angeschaut, was vor ein paar Monaten
raus, nein? Oder? Weiß nicht,
muss mal einen Link schicken.
Komm, wir gucken
noch eine Runde. Wir gucken
noch eine Runde MW2.
Da hab ich jetzt noch mal Bock getroffen.
Afghan!
Das ist bestimmt wieder so ein schönes
5 Kills Predator
Ding, Predator Harrier Nuke
oder Harrier Chopper Gunner
Nuke Video.
TGF
Tuning Pack.
Ich glaube, das haben wir uns
schon mal angeguckt.
TGF, ja, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt. Das war
Haare sträuben, das Ding.
Heck fragt
Wie würdest du am besten den Einstieg in Linux
angehen? Würde mich gerne ein bisschen das Thema
Linux Shell einarbeiten, habe mir zum
Gaming PC ein Laptop geholt und bin am
überlegen, dort Linux drauf zu packen. Hast du eine
Empfehlung für eine Distro? Hab mir mal Deepin,
Ubuntu und Manjaro angeschaut. Also
ich würde dir empfehlen, nimm Linux Mint als
Einstieg und mach dir kein eigenes
Gerät, mach's wie ich hier, installiere
so viele PP Gas, installiere eine
VM, mach dir eine VM auf deine
auf deine fette Linux
fette Desktop Gaming
Geschichte, machst du dir VM
bei Workstation oder Virtual Box drauf
und installierst die Linux da drinnen,
weil dann bist du auch viel einfacher
in der Handhabung drumherum.
Komm.
Bro
What? How did this get
There's no way I survive here
I'm dead serious
I'm seconds from death
Jetzt erstmal schön
Shotgun, oh
The fact that he just randomly
chucks his C4 in there
Das ist auch die beste Map für
Harrier und AC 130
und Chopper Gun und alles
Enemy AC 130 above
Oh, there's a bunch at A though
It's a 6v6
and there's so many people noobtubing
You're right, what am I saying
Die Gegner checken heute noch genauso
wenig wie 2010
Oh, Painkiller
So eine Kacke, weinegüt
habe ich mich da immer drüber aufgeregt
Ich habe einen Painkiller
Ich hatte eine 6k und eine 5k
Die habe ich direkt zerstört
Ich mochte nicht
Burstwaffen in dem Game
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil ich zu PP gar
Aime
Komm, push him
Ich wäre schon längst gesniped
worden vom Berg aus
Careful
Wann musstest du das letzte Mal
Cacken? Du meinst
Ich Cack W die ganze Zeit
Die Gegner klingen ganz schön auf den Sack
Guckt euch das mal an
Überall grüne Pfeile
Gegner poppen auf
Gegner tot
Ah, jetzt gibts auf den Sack
Jetzt gibts
Oh, da hinten spawnen gleich 5 Leute auf einmal
Ich muss jetzt mal was sagen
Ich gebe zu
Als Gegner macht das bestimmt keinen Spaß gerade
Bäm, gleich mal nuke
Oh, die klingeln aber auch richtig
krass auf die Fresse gerade
Jetzt double nuke
Was war das gerade
Ich weiß nicht
4 Minuten nuke, das geht aber nicht
Das muss schneller sein
Das ist immer halt
In MW2 war Nuke schon zu einfach
Einen guten Killstreak an Start gekriegt
Glück gehabt ein bisschen mit dem AC130
Easy Nuke
Ja, die haben keinen Bock
Ich würde auch Rage quitten
Max und MW2
Belegt ist Pro
Dankeschön für den Sub
2 Monate
Ja, aber das ist nur
Das ist jetzt nur mal ausstabtsweise
So viel MW2 gucken wir nun auch wieder nicht
Ja, man hatte damals zu wenig Nukes
Weil die Gegner Rage quitten konnten
Und das Spiel abgekackt ist
Die sind ja fast bei jedem
Bei jedem Game, wo man mal einen guten Streak hatte
Mit Nuke oder mit Nuke Potential
Wurde das Game ja gequittet
Und auch direkt
Genau, direkt Dashboard
Direkt
Moment, hat er den gerade
Hat er den gerade gemessert
Also jetzt wird es aber eng für die Double Nuke
Jetzt wird es für die Double Nuke aber eng
Wat
Oh, die Gegner
Wie kann er so ruhig bleiben
Wahrscheinlich indem er seine
Oder es gibt ja Leute
Die sind ultra entspannt
Also ich habe letztens mal
Wieder versucht MW2 zu spielen
Auf der Xbox One
Mit Backwards Compatibility
Hat keine Games gefunden
Black Ops 1 hat gefunden
Nein
Ja, er läuft noch
Auf der Xbox One kann er Black Ops 1 spielen
Also ich habe es erst
Vor kurzem gespielt
Da hast du ein bisschen Game gefunden
Aber geht
Du hast die Spaß anstatt
Jetzt sieht man wieder
Dass die Nuke zu einfach waren
In MW2
Knapp
Zum Glück haben beide
Gerade
Aber es hat ja auch seinen Scham gehabt
Dass alles in dem Game
Wie OP war
Das wird knapp mit der Nuke
Aber ich meine es wird eine Nuke
Weil wir wissen es aus dem Titel
Oh, Callouts hier
Wer spielt MW2
Callouts
Oh da, das fetzt jetzt richtig
Zwei Nuke vor Schluss
Zwei Nuke vor zwei Punkten
Vor Schluss
Callouts
Nice Gameplay
Das ist immer wieder nice zu gucken
Das ist echt immer wieder nice zu schauen
Easy Clap
Zum Glück hat er noch geneift
Ja sonst wäre das nicht validated
Sonst wäre das nicht legit Nuke gewesen
Wer ist denn Kugelmagnet
Eddy habe ich noch nie was von gehört
Aber da scheinen viele Zuschauer zu haben
Ich habe ja nie was von gehört
Battlefield
Warzone
Warzone geht ja so ab gerade
Alle die Warzone Content machen
Da geht es steil aufwärts
Nur leider irgendwie habe ich keinen Bock
Warzone Content zu machen
Bei mir fängt es schon wieder an
Dass ich echt irgendwie
Abneigung habe das Spiel zu starten
Die Server gehen steil abwärts
Dedicated Servers
On all platforms
Sie grabliert
Was
Software in Android
Das ist ein Problem
Ach die gibt es auch noch
Battlefield 1
Wie kann man so lange Battlefield 5 spielen
Ich habe es nicht länger
Als kurz nach der Beta ausgehalten
Battlefield 3 Reality Mod
Also sprich Treffer Tod
Oder wie oder was oder wo
Wo gibt es das
Download
Es wäre cool wenn es einer schaffen würde
Battlefield 3 zu modden
So dass ein paar wieder Leute spielen
Jetzt gerade in Anbetracht der Tatsache
Dass Battlefield 5
Dead ist
Vom Support her
KyoKun habe ich
Gestern auch gelesen
Auf Twitter hat einer geschrieben
320% Package Lost
Wo ich mich frage wie kann man mehr Packages verlieren
Als man los schickt
Aber in Modern Warfare ist das anscheinend kein Problem
Easy
So Leute
Ich muss übelst dringend aufs Klo
Und was essen
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream
Und dann hoffentlich
Mit Vodafone was besser funktioniert
Bis dann
Machts gut CO